vous êtes là qu'est ce que c'est que ce
bordel
est ce un simple problème d'électronique
ou un poltergeist a provoqué ce qui
vient de se passer
ah oui on est là pour se faire peur oui
oui les amis aujourd'hui je ne vais pas
vous lire un thread twitter aurait dit
ou quoi que ce soit mais je vais vous
parler de mes trois histoires d'horreur
préférés dont l'une qui est celle qui
m'a fait mettre un pas dans le
paranormal et qui m'a fait adorer ça et
surtout adoré les films d'horreur c'est
vraiment grâce à cette histoire là voilà
je vais devoir un peu synthétiser tout
ça puis je mettais des sources dans la
description sur na qui veulent lire avec
précision certains trucs je trouve ça
passionnant on commence avec l'exorcisme
de michel anne lise weppes tête je vais
me reconvertir dans la voix off il
s'agit du cas de possession démoniaque
le plus connu de l'histoire et l'on
n'est plus documenté il ya même eu deux
films dessus tellement cette histoire
est connue c'est celle ci qui m'a fait
plonger dans le paranormal je vais vous
la conter avec un plaisir des mesures et
analyse michel est une jeune allemand né
le 21 septembre 1952 à l'ide fring en
bavière je ne parlerai plus allemand
désolée elle fait partie d'une famille
catholique très croyante elle va jusqu'à
faire pénitence pour faire pardonner les
péchés des autres en plus des siens elle
est vraiment impliqué dans le péché game
vraiment tout se passe bien jusqu'à ses
16 ans donc jusqu'en 68 ou là elle
commence à avoir des crises de
convulsions elle est alors diagnostiqué
épileptique par les médecins mais ça ne
va pas s'arrêter là
son état continue de se détériorer les
crises sont plus en plus nombreuses et
il pense du coup qu'il ya un problème
psychologique derrière ça alors il
l'envoie dans un hôpital psychiatrique
pendant une année ça ne s'améliore pas
c'est même pire qu'avant en plus de ça
elle elle tombe en dépression donc c'est
vraiment la totale pour la peau valises
michel qui va alors commencer à parler
de possession démoniaque elle va
commencer à être persuadé qu'elle est
possédée par des démons à tel point
qu'elle va se mettre à rejeter les
symboles catholiques comme les crucifix
d'habibou tous à l asthme est à chier
là-dessus vraiment comme si elle en
voulait à l'église de ne rien faire pour
elle alors qu'elle est convaincue
qu'elle est possédée elle le crie sur
tous les toits sa situation va ensuite
s'arranger elle va sortir de l'hôpital
elle va reprendre le chemin de la foi
elle va se remettre à prier à croire
mais elle surveille ces derrières elles
gardent quand même une petite fiole
d'eau bénite tu vois dans la poche
arrière au cas où il ya un démon ban
dans la gueule à partir de là la pauvre
c'est une descente aux enfers eu à
proprement parler puisqu'on parle de
démons et où anne lise va se remettre à
part les possessions démoniaques même
plus que ça elle va commencer à dire
qu'elle voit des visages démoniaque
elle va se mettre aussi entendre des
voix 2
cité diabolique elle est convaincue que
ces médicaments n'arrange rien elle en
prend pour traiter ces problèmes
d'épilepsie pour traiter sa dépression
pour traiter même la schizophrénie je
crois enfin bref les médecins il
s'acharne un peu sur elle donc du coup
elle va arrêter d'un coup de prendre
tous ces médicaments et c'est une très
mauvaise idée
pendant toutes ces années l'église
refuse de pratiquer un exorcisme sur
anne lise étant donné qu'elle est
persuadée d'être possédé c'est un effet
très destructeur pour elle mais en 75 un
curé va porter l affaire devant l'église
va les convaincre de pratiquer des
exercices au cours des exorcismes les
prêtres diagnostic qu'il y aurait
plusieurs entités qui sont rentrés dans
le corps de anne lise entre autres néron
lucifer et hitler le comportement d'anne
lise est de pire en pire elle hurlé mort
les prêtres elle se met même à manger
des insectes avaient commencé à se
mutiler aussi bref tous les signes que
l'église considère comme des signes de
possession démoniaque
elle les a et surtout il ya un
enregistrement audio qui a été fait lors
d'un exorcisme et là on entend la voix
de admise et qu'elle soit posséder ou
pas on s'en fout c'est assez troublant
parce qu'on entend quand même une
personne en détresse mais un très court
extrait qui vous fera badé mais pas trop
non plus mais c'est vous dire à quel
point c'est sérieux en fait ce qui s'est
passé avec cette personne c'est pas une
légende
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à
le 1er juillet 76 anne-lise décède
elle meurt à l'âge de 25 ans après des
années de souffrance et cette histoire a
fait d'elle le cas de possession
démoniaque le plus connu de l'histoire
ça c'est l'histoire comme les gens
aiment la raconter si sauf qu'il ya un
décor qui est beaucoup plus glauque
après ça c'est à dire qu'il ya un procès
qui a commencé en mars 78 et qui a
accusé en fait les prêtres qui ont
pratiqué des exercices mais les parents
d'anne lise de négligence entraînant la
mort d'une personne
le procès était assez dingue et
emblématique parce que ça opposé
l'église qui parlait de faits
surnaturels comme de possession
démoniaque à la science les médecins qui
a expliqué que le comportement d'anne
lise était lié à tous les médicaments
qu'elle prenait leurs effets secondaires
et aussi à l'arrêt brutal de cela c'est
dire que c'est des traitements lourds et
quand t'arrêtes en plein milieu ça mais
ton cerveau un peu en bordel résultat du
procès les parents d'analyser les
prêtres furent condamnés à six mois de
prison avec sursis pourquoi parce qu'en
fait il y avait eu non lieu ça donnait
raison aux prête d'avoir eu ces
pratiques là sur anne lise et serait
surtout montré que la justice voit la
possession démoniaque comme une réalité
et non plus comme un mythe ou quelque
chose de pas normal mais on n'a pas de
preuves sexe vraiment voilà ça c'est ouf
comme histoire ça me posait vraiment le
paranormal et la science est ce que rim
c'est que les symptômes d'une possession
démoniaque
si ça existe sont vraiment très très
proches voire exactement les mêmes que
les effets secondaires de certains
médicaments que tu prends quand un
traitement lourd en contre certains
problèmes psychologiques entre autres
donc du coup ce procès était compliqué
et ça rend l'histoire assez folle et en
tout cas à mieux de michèle paix à son
âme et c'est horrible ce qu'elle a vécu
et voilà que ce soit une potion
démoniaque ou juste après musicologique
c'est affreux bon matin vous n'allez pas
dormir bas autant que je continue je
vous raconte une deuxième histoire je
suis le père castor de ma génération
l'histoire de robert robert doll une
histoire qui m'a marqué de ouf parce que
c'est l'une des rares histoires qui
contient une poupée en tes pages crois
que c'est la seule en fait avec
annabelle et surtout cette de
poupées lengel un peu atypique on a
souvent parlé poupée dans les vidéos
mais regardez-moi ça qu'est ce que c'est
que ça qui à design et ce truc en 1906
robert janotto est un jeune enfant qui
vit en floride et qui se voient offrir
une poupée il est encore enfant à ce
moment là quand il reçoit la poupée elle
fait carrément sa taille et c'est la
servante de la famille de la maison
originaire des bahamas qui lui a offert
cette poupée et
les vues comme une personne qui pratique
un peu la magie noire et le vaudou la
théorie c'est qu'elle a offert cette
poupée aux fils de la famille pour se
venger du calvaire qu'elle vivait à
cause d'eux alors robert trouvé que la
poupée lui ressembler dons qui lui a
donné son nom au calme la poupée appelle
donc robert ellis les appeler par sa
famille par son deuxième prénom eugène
pour moi j'ai un gros début de
schizophrénie mais ainsi soit il
il va rapidement y avoir un problème
avec cette poupée cet enfant puisque les
parents ils entendent le gel par les uns
roberge dans sachant les entende de voix
différentes saissac et glauque alors les
enfants souvent des amis imaginaires
en tout cas ils ont créé donc ils se
disent que leur fils interprète tout
simplement la voix de sa poupée robert
ainsi que la sienne et il converse à sa
poupée sauf qu'en fait il c'est lui qui
fait les questions et les réponses
quelques années plus tard les parents
vont changer d'avis parce que live peut
être question de simple petite
conversation entre les deux ils
entendent la poupée crier sur ce gène et
lui donner des ordres
aucun robert il prend un melon mon pote
n'a jamais vu ça les parents ont même
dit que quand il serait entré dans la
chambre et voyait eugène dans un coin de
la pièce en pls et robert posé sur une
chaise au calme elle était une poupée tu
redescends mon pote hockey souvent quand
les parents rentrer chez eux après être
allé en vacances ou cinéma y retrouvait
des trucs cassé dans la maison et le
pauvre jane il avait rien fait du coup
il répondait robert dit c'est à dire
c'est robert qui a fait ça cette phrase
aujourd'hui à l'écomusée un peu dans les
familles en floride quand un gamin fait
une bêtise et 10 heures robert dit
tellement c'est vous dire à quel point
l'histoire de robert doll est connue
là-bas
le temps passe les années passent les
parents de gênes décède c'est triste
mais c'est la vie c'est comme ça que ça
se passe aux gènes se retrouve alors à
vivre dans la maison de ses parents s'en
sépare en bourse et un adulte maintenant
il a 30 enfin tu vois là il se retrouve
donc avec une chambre entre ou qu'est-ce
qu'on fait qu'on a une poupée en trop
une chambre entre hauts et bas on unit
les deux voilà pour que la poupée et sa
petite chambre à l e j'aime c'est quoi
la jane va ensuite étudié l'art à paris
puis revient vivre dans cette fameuse
maison des années plus tard avec son
épouse anne se gênent et continue de
parler à robert la poupée hamel se dit
mais qu'est ce que c'est que ce bordel
ça dure ça dure ça dure et un jour elle
fait elle négocie robert ça dégage ça va
au grenier voilà et là c'est très très
de l'autre puisque les voisins vont se
mettre à aller voir au gène en lui
disant mec bien
grenier qui bouge robert la poupée se
met aux fenêtres du grenier puis bouge
passe d'une fenêtre à l'autre calmement
ok mais eugène refuse de jeter robert à
la poubelle anne ça va la rendre folle
folle folle folle folle quelques années
plus tard en décèdent paix à son âme
il ya plein de voisins qui pensent que
robert dit on arrive à 74 ans eugène
décès de la maison est vendue une
famille bien ménager là et a toujours
robert au grenier bah oui c'est soit son
foyer et c'est ouf parce que la famille
a constaté que leur petite fille de 10
ans mais tu es à développer une relation
imaginaire avec cette poupée avec robert
et on peut voir robert dans une cloche
en verre dans un fort qui est devenu je
crois un musée des horreurs ou chez
boutreau poids mais bref et en fait
quand on passe devant il faut lui
demander la permission de prendre une
photo et apparemment il aurai en t
quelques visiteurs du truc quoi qu'il en
soit c'est génial l'histoire et que les
poupées enfin ce génial ira vivre c'est
un peu moins génial apparemment cette
histoire là m'avait aussi énormément
fait kiffer et puis surtout la gueule
atypique de la poupée quoi mec c'est fou
n'est-il pas temps de passer à la
troisième histoire
ce n est pas dégueu seul alors déjà qu
est ce qu un poltergeist ça vient du
coût de l'aliment poltergay c'est le
dérivé de paul terme qui veut dire faire
du bruit et guest qui veut dire esprit
il s'agit donc d'un phénomène paranormal
consistant en des boues divers des
déplacements apparitions disparitions
d'objets ou autre phénomène a priori
inexplicable oui j'étais sur wikipédia
on bat les couilles nous sommes en 1977
à enfield une ville
d'angleterre des gardes sans vie dans
une petite maison avec ses quatre
enfants et elle va être témoin de
phénomènes paranormaux ça va partir en
couille et j'adore cette histoire déjà
parce qu'elle a inspiré le film
d'horreur préféré conjurer une d'eau et
surtout parce que c'est le cas
d'apparition de phénomènes paranormaux
le plus documenté de l'histoire du
poltergeist en vrille aurait matière à
faire une vidéo juste sur cette histoire
là mais vu qu'elle est extrêmement connu
et que d'autres ont déjà fait je vais
pas vous faire ça je vais juste vous
dire les grands traits de l'histoire et
pour les curieux vous allez voir en
détail mais c'est hyper intéressant et
johnson vit dans une petite maison à une
fille comme je ne vous le dirais l'élève
ses quatre enfants là bas
margaret 13 ans janet 11 ans johnny 10
ans et billy sept ans nous sommes le 31
août aux alentours de 21h donc c'est pas
très tard en plus et peggy est posée
dans sa chambre en train de dormir
lorsqu'elle entend un crissement qui
vient de la chambre des enfants elle
rejoint la chambre en courant les deux
enfants sourds éveillé relevé dans leur
lit et disputent un moment on a peur il
faut savoir que la veille ses enfants
lui avaient dit la maman au secours
nolly bouge tout seul au score ne bouge
tout seul cette fois ci c'était la
chaise qui apparemment bouger tout seul
péguy calmes les enfants elle regagne sa
chambre mais elles rentrent en un petit
glissement bizarre elle retourne dans la
chambre et là il ya quatre toques qui
proviennent les murs de la maison comme
du coeur de la maison et là la commode
donc une commode c'est très lourd qui
est située contre un mur ce mr décollé
du mur et a bouché comme s'il y avait
une entité qui l'a poussé vraiment avec
une force démesurée ce qui fait un peu
flipper quand même donc sur le coup pegi
elle a pas d'explication rationnelle à
ce qui vient de se passer elle prend une
sage décision c'est venez tous
on dort tous dans le salon ensemble
c'est la meilleure idée payer va alors
aller chercher de l'aide auprès de ses
voisins en les suppliant de venir dans
sa maison pour inspecter avec elle parce
qu'il s'est passé un truc pas très
normal quand même alors ils vont
commencer à se balader dans la maison il
ya ces fameux toc toc qui vont continuer
d'apparaître mais ils apparaissent
toujours autour de la ou paigc et ses
voisins se trouve dans la maison c'est
comme si quelqu'un était enfermée dans
les parois de la maison est ok à
l'endroit où ils sont en se déplaçant
même temps que pour leur faire peur aux
alentours de 23 heures ils ont toujours
pas d'explication logique donc payer
elle se dit bon bah ça se trouve c'est
vraiment quelqu'un qui est venu dans la
maison donc dans le doute j'ai appelé la
police pour qu'ils enquêtent la police
sur amen
il rentre dans la maison tout est très
calme d'un coup j'ai entendre les fameux
toc toc et là l'un des fauteuils du
salon ce mec
m sur le sol les policiers qu'est ce que
tu veux qu'ils fassent si c'est un truc
paranormal c'est un truc paranormal les
flics y peuvent rien faire c'est peu il
faut appeler qu'il faut appeler peggy
contacter la presse est un gars de la
presse qui est sensible à ça il
s'appelle george pal aux et va sur les
lieux il entend les fameux coups et
décide de contacter un organisme pour
gérer la faire ça fait la une de
plusieurs journaux tout le monde parle
de ça souvent il ya des journalistes des
enquêteurs devant la maison bref du coup
la famille vit un enfer ils sont
fatigués ont du mal à dormir en plus ya
ça à partir de là les manifestations
surnaturelles se multiplier et elle
semble être centrée autour de djanet par
exemple c'est janet qui se réveille en
pleine nuit avec une sensation de
suffoquer comme si quelqu'un lui avait
fait serrer les mains sur la bouche
c'est vers djanet que les objets volent
bref ça a l'air vraiment d'être autour
d'elle maurice gross qui fait partie du
fameux institut qui enquête sur le
paranormal est régulièrement chez la
famille de peggy pour être témoins des
phénomènes et voir ce qu'il peut faire
comme je vous ai dit c'est souvent
autour de djanet que ça se passe et une
nuits janet se réveille en hurlant elle
vous dans tous les sens ça l'excité
maurice et c de la can mais miss fait
mordre ça finit par une petite injection
d'un produit pour la calmer et au final
elle est diagnostiqué schizophrène ça
fait un peu penser justement au cas de
denise c'est ça qui est horrible
abatteurs de la ya plein de photos de
djanet qui vont être prises janet qui
volent contre la radio la célèbre photo
de djanet qu'il évite au dessus de son
lit
même si on dirait qu'elles sortent un
clairement et alors du coup voilà ça que
rip c est ce que tout ça est un gros
fake organisée par la famille ou est-ce
que c'est réel les enquêteurs
s'enchaînent les médiums s'enchaînent ya
un nombre de gens qui passent dans cette
maison pour voir ça et pour essayer
d'arranger la situation c'est
incalculable l'histoire prend forme en
soixante dix huit genres ya tellement de
trucs par normand dans la maison qu'ils
sont habitués janet quand il se couche
elle est projetée hors du lit elle se
met à voler c'est normal ça devient
normal viala une décision qui est prise
c'est qu'elle aille en hôpital
psychiatrique elle va dans le meilleur
hôpital psychiatrique du monde
elle va y rester trois mois avant de
rentrer chez elle et à partir de là tout
se calme même s'il ya encore des fois
des témoignages d'apparition de la part
des enfants de peggy disent avoir vu un
vieux monsieur aux un enfant et voit la
fin de l'histoire janet est toujours en
vie et elle a témoigné plein de foi de
tout ça de son enfance un peu
mouvementée et alors la question et gros
problèmes psychologiques
ouvrez poltergeist comme pour anne lise
c'est ça qu'il faut avec ses histoires
j'adore mes amis j'espère que ça vous a
plu n'hésitez pas aimé la vidéo si c'est
le cas et j'espère vous n'allez pas vous
même
à voler au dessus de votre lit cette
nuit qui aura pas de poltergeist qu'il y
aura pas d toc toc qui viennent des murs
tout ça durera pas robert sedan le
souligner qui met des petits coups comme
ça entre deux là pour vous empêcher de
dormir voilà je voulais trop parler de
ces trois histoires parce qu'elles sont
fascinantes et elles sont extrêmement
documenté fente cassé les deux cas de
possession démoniaque de poltergeist qui
sont les plus connus est pas pour rien
quoi celui là celui de djanet le nombre
de photos de témoignages de vie c'est
incroyable je fais plein de bisous
j'espère que ces petits trucs on parle
d'histoires d'horreur fou qui fait moi
j'adore d'un je kiffe tellement je suis
vraiment content d'avoir pu vous
raconter ces trois histoires là qui
m'ont fasciné c'est vraiment grâce à ça
que j'ai aimé le paranormal et je me
suis mis à les intéresser même si j'y
crois pas en fait j'ai jamais voler au
dessus de mon lit comme janelle tu vois
je peux pas y croire du coup mais bon
ceux qui y croient je respecte en
attendant je vous fais des gros bisous
bonne nuit
tous